I was gonna take the [ __ ] thing off
of this not happening cuz are they
paying you
oh my god are you ready hey are you
ready okay ladies and gentlemen once
again this after thanksgiving special on
your favorite podcast
[Music]
I really can't do the whoo booze I'm
still sick from Thanksgiving but I'm
making an attempt but anyway I was
offered that woo the singer Mike to the
[Music]
[Music]
terrible already no more singing cuz I
can't do it it sounds good it's a new it
look at that was nice there's extra
character to it there's extra character
to it yeah a little more R&B now get on
the mic are you under my yeah I think so
that's better okay anyways ladies and
gentlemen I know you're looking and
you're like I don't know who the hell
that is
you will yeah well but uh this is like
talk about this guy a lot on the podcast
I always make reference to like my crazy
friend or like my movie buddy or you
know or weird or he's super weird
whatever I say but this is him right
here or so I said let me get him on the
podcast ran out of guests no we're not
actually have really big guest coming up
so you're like in the middle of this can
honor it's an honor god I can't even
this is how we gonna start off okay this
is when you bring your friends on this
is this is what happens but ladies
general welcome to the podcast mr. Ben
thank you thank you for having me
Benjamin Siebert okay well you're here
well thank you don't act like I pushed
it on you I never mentioned it once
you're finally yeah I never mentioned it
I was a very good friend about it I was
like it'll happen when it happens and
then he surprised me and said you see
how are we sir they're coming on yeah
well you're here and you actually listen
to the put your like a podcast you're a
pilot and everyone's yeah who do you
listen to the most I don't know if there
is a most I mean who just in the podcast
where you like watch it - i watch all of
them cuz I cuz I used to hang out with
you
a lot more at the Comedy Store so I know
a lot of them and it's really cool to
watch everyone shows so I've been
watching your since day one obviously
and then I watch a lot of Rogan like
everyone does I feel like and then all
the Callen stuff daliyah's stuff yeah I
watch all those guys broken always
surprises me with like it'll be some
it'll be like your normal like big guest
or something like that yeah presidential
candidate and then you branch on a small
comic yeah or not even just a small
comic he'll just bring in like it'll be
like here's the you know the the
scientists are just invented like oh
yeah yeah they're the cure for something
those are the ones I love the money yeah
yeah those are the we learned all the
most important [ __ ] from those like yes
he had a really good sleep specialist on
once right after that episode I've been
going to bed at 10 p.m.
ever since I was like changed my life
you know all those guys all the
everything I've learned about like
health has basically come from his show
and not from doctors so I know some
blacks on ya know I don't I don't just
go like whatever anyone says on this
show has you know is it but I've
definitely been able to pick out some
really helpful stuff on that show
no but it's amazing how the internet
even has like a stigma to it of like you
know it's like oh well it was on the
internet so oh right we're right so it's
not true because we're it is true both
ways yeah people use it as like yeah it
doesn't go both ways some people will be
like oh you can't don't believe anything
anything on the internet don't believe
in here and then people that believe
everything try to be
it's like going to WebMD anytime you
have like a I stopped doing that yeah me
too cuz I have AIDS forever yeah that
was one of our first like the first
times we connected to friends actually
I'm glad that came up was I don't know
if you remember this was me when I lived
in Venice still so this is way early oh
yeah you live that lived in everywhere
in LA so when I lived in Venice for like
two months or whatever I my anxiety was
at its worst and I was like feeling a
tingling at the back of my neck which I
know I now know was just like a
manifestation of anxiety but at the time
when I looked it up it was like that's
French paralysis and I remember telling
you that being like dude it says I
French paralysis and you laughing
so hard and being like you'll realize
that how funny that is eventually you're
in it now but that's hilarious you're
fine yeah I was fine no but I can't
stand looking up because sometimes
you'll look up something and it'll be
like you know you no matter what it is
you always only see the worst Akasa
bleep yeah I know yeah I don't know why
they show you yeah it'll be a symptom of
a cold right there like that's also a
symptom of you Gary my shoulder is you
know I don't know yeah I hadn't even
heard of French paralysis and I was like
I have it but I literally have not been
on WebMD since then yeah I don't
sometimes you want to check because you
have something like sometimes going on
my foot right right so my heel was
hurting so a lot of times I think it's
like what is that called
flasher pani plantar fasciitis so I
thought it was that but then like you're
looking it up and then there's something
else it's like you know foot foot cancer
you have foot AIDS and I'm like oh no
where's my foot man but I but so then
but then they say you got to go damn
then you end up going to the doctor but
I don't know if you've noticed but like
do you have sagging insurance from doing
all you're right I'm back on it now I've
been on and off look man is an actor
he's on the up and coming you know
up-and-coming struggle and I actually
referenced man a lot with with things
cuz I don't you distance in a podcast so
no you're at home you probably listening
and probably yeah I don't get frustrated
actually even when you call me weird I'm
just like that's fine I'll explain one
day I don't know but Bette has been like
you know just in the scene and he's
actually things have been moving more
for better for you right now yeah
back-to-back opposite years 2018 was my
worst year I didn't work all year until
October one job and then that was it for
the year and then this year I did a
Grayson Frankie coming out next year I
did that in February I did a Wendy's
commercial for the for March Madness
which aired literally just for March
Madness I got a weekend out of that and
then and then like I was kind of high
off that for a couple months and then I
got um a couple bit parts on shows in
like August and September well I love
how you're finally starting to listen to
me because I remember you I mean go
ahead yeah no but our this is one of the
great examples okay this is another
story I haven't told on this one yet but
this is another one about you okay so
you just well first of all Ben got
sucker at you know fostering dogs
suckered and it's a it's a racket
because they know when you get these
dogs in your place you're never gonna
let them go
some people somehow do I don't know how
they do have there are some people that
regularly foster dogs those are my
cousins or monsters yeah if you can get
a dog in your life if you start loving
it and then you just give it away I
don't know just like people to an
unbelievable level of selflessness that
we can't relate to you they're working
like a burn unit like for kids yeah and
you're like you have to see these kids
suffering all the time and yet have to
have there has to be a biscuit
I'm not built for that either so so they
find people who are not built for that
and they go there's some dogs he's he's
vulnerable
yeah he's vulnerable so then got like
some so you had do a foster for the mom
three puppies right but I love that it's
like a conspiracy to you it really just
did happen very naturally I was gonna
happen naturally like no but I assume
well yeah I guess yeah it could be yeah
cuz I assumed because it was all young
like single women involved right before
they got to me I was like oh these
they've all been claimed I'm this is
definitely gonna be a fostering
situation but all these girls are gonna
each want one of the puppies and so many
dogs and then I found out none of them
were claimed except for the mom so I
mean dude they were like breakable when
I had them you know I said actually I'm
rip these dogs away from their mother
nope pushed them away if you know
anything about dogs which I'm sure you
as the watcher and listener do the mom
pushes them away actually they she act
she actively is like alright we're done
now you get off like cuz they'll be
still chasing her tit and stuff and
she's like an official growl at him and
[ __ ] she really was like get out of here
and then that's when finally they're
done
and I think theoretically you're
actually supposed to separate the
brothers too because we've dealt with
some fights over the years yes you have
so then I wait so he has these dogs and
he's living in this place that only lets
you have two dogs which is 98 to 99
percent of but places in LA but in my
opinion I think it's ridiculous because
to me it should be a what's the
difference a poundage situation for sure
it should be like one of them is this
[ __ ] yeah if you have like you know
three dogs and there are a total of 48
pounds right but you can have 250 pound
dog right it's a hundred percent so we
should be like when you go to Whole
Foods and you get the thing and you put
it on the scale that's what it should be
yeah I often think of them go to the
renter's place and you go like okay I
have 62 pounds of dog and they're like
okay yeah
anybody fits for dogs but anyway I agree
so we had to move so been well I didn't
have to what what happened was she was
like it was ridiculous she goes uh she
goes like you could only have two of
them but I would like I want money for
all three I wanted to posit for all
three so it's like well that's psychotic
and so it was like the decision was
pretty clear to move but there's a lot
of slumlords in LA dude it was you know
really sucks man because that I talked
about it and I'm gonna try not to say
this if a bunch of topics that I talked
about on the show I just started come up
but I'm been also just started a podcast
so he's worried about my overlap Ben no
I'm not worried about overlap I'm
worried about making the statement I
talked about this on my show and I want
to say that too many times don't okay
all right we're gonna but since he
brought it up here we go everybody who
Ben she like whatever we got stickers
made it's ready to go all right so no I
[ __ ] what we were talking about the
slumlord later oh yeah no that sucked
because the original woman who we moved
in with who was the manager was so cool
she was super laid back super nice very
sweet does personable and then this
woman took over and the way she said
hello to everyone in the building was
with a pay today or get out on the 2nd
of January so if you didn't pay on New
Year's Day she was giving you a fiction
notices that was how she introduced
herself
so that was the woman who was like and
pay me three times you know whatever
they just wanted you to leave I wanted
to leave he probably put the owner of
that building probably put her in place
to drive everybody out oh yes hundred
dollars a month you know how much do i
paying in that same unit now fifteen I
bet they were like going there be a
[ __ ] and drive everybody out well it
worked it worked man but anyways the
point I'm trying to get to is like so
yeah these three dollars didn't move and
then he was like gonna move to a place
where I was like I remember this
specifically I don't know if you should
move into that place Bennet so it seems
a little pricey mm-hmm but you were like
it's okay I just had this McDonald's
commercial that's how it goes that's
been the friend I tried to tell you yeah
as it McDonald's commercial don't pay
yeah you know one run yeah you got eight
weeks and then it's gone yeah I got
lucky and that's not a lot of money to a
normal person though I know but not for
LA not for LA not for like if you're
using that to pay your rent right well I
mean that well the thing is though it I
made it a year down there you know it
did get me through the year and I've
still been paying basically that price
ever since you're talking about downtown
right yeah yeah yeah but you can things
are better now but and then you can live
downtown which it's like it's so funny
because where you live - downtown
used to be you ten years ago that was
tent city right there
well one block over is where I got the
gun pulled on me do they keep moving it
they keep moving
they keep gentrifying and it's dude oh
yeah when I moved I always described it
as like it's like dropping ice cubes
into a cup of water the water is not
going anywhere it's just gonna fall
outside of the cup yes and that's
exactly what happens down there they
throw a really nice coffee shop in there
where the beans are dated the day before
from Belize or whatever yeah you know
it's the best coffee you can get in the
world but literally 30 second walk away
is where a dude pushed a gun into my hip
at 2:00 in the morning yeah that place
is weird I mean I just think downtown is
so weird because of that exact thing
it's like you go down there during the
day and you go wow look at this little
hip coffee shop in this hip restaurant
and there's all these people walking
around and there's a lot of dogs down
there it's like a lot of us Coast
transplants they still think they're in
New York and yeah but then like as soon
as like 8 o'clock
dude people just start walking down the
street staring at themselves it's like
it's a it's a different
Ashkelon of of like dire straights down
there like the homeless people like
there's homeless people all over LA but
it'll be like a group of people and
they're talking to each other like
people downtown it'll be an individual
by themselves screaming at themselves
walking down the street it's a different
and this is level and then you're like
this is like in front of you are you
know $3,500 a month yeah you know studio
apartment they're like you know
overcharging you for yes sir because
they did a Whole Foods in at the corner
yeah and the people that make it work
down there that's kind of why I left was
they just they obviously just numb
themselves to it because I remember
being in the coffee shop down there I
used to go to all the time and something
crazy was happening as it always does
you know that's it's like everything to
do it there's a duality but it's so
sharp and contrasted where you're like
this is amazing I get this coffee it's
one minute walk away but in that minute
when I cross the street I do got hit by
a car behind me and while I'm getting
the coffee there's a fistfight and
you're going like Jesus what's going on
out there and the guy making your coffee
just goes like I don't know and you go I
don't want to be like that and so you
you either stay and become that or you
get the [ __ ] out and I got the [ __ ] out
no he's gone now I live in a quiet quiet
suburb where I'm probably the only
person making noise there well your your
your mongrels or I'm very lucky they're
not the only psychos in that little mini
Motel complex I live in all the dogs
that live there a lunatic thank God so
no one can blame just me you're a dog
person you weren't were you always a dog
person yeah man I knew dogs when you
were a kid I grew up with dogs I didn't
even know and um yeah but it's weird man
when you grow up with dogs I guess like
some kids cuz I've seen all these videos
online now if like babies being like
real close with dogs I didn't give a
[ __ ] about the dog I grew up with until
I was a little bit older it's weird like
I just all the home video footage of our
family I'm just ignoring the dog
completely oh he's always in the
background but then eventually as I got
older and that dog passed on and then my
parents got new dogs and I got closer to
them but I'd never had you know my own
dog these are the first dogs
where I was like oh [ __ ] this is what
it's like to to like have an animal for
real it's a it's a very different thing
than just you know having a dog in the
house yeah you told you really have to
take care of them and yeah this is like
a it's like a well you know they doin
all these studies I've been reading
about that like when you have a dog you
know you're healthier are you because
yeah because of the bacteria you get
from them no I think it's because of
like or mentally mentally healthier and
also like because of like you having to
the act of having to take care of them
there's a goal and pull you into the
moment a lot more you know like you're
especially with this acting [ __ ] and you
know how I am with it I get just when we
were at the at the football game the
other day I get very distracted when
it's when it's when there's news you
know it's like there's something like
you're on a veil now don't think about
it for 24 hours and I'm like all right
and I've gotten a lot better at it and
that's really I mean obviously it's half
of it is figuring out how to exist in
between and all the famous actors talk
about that [ __ ] too and obviously they
have less time in between than I do
but that's what I always say is about
managing disappointment yeah like I
don't want to be a psychopath and be
like you know like not feel Annie don't
feel and writing right no but I'm saying
like let yourself feel as much as you
can handle yeah yeah and then be able to
handle the disappoint right that right
so you so the thing is like not letting
your son cuz what I thought you were
doing before was letting your like
myself you get let down too much right
and then the drop that's not sustainable
there and then zin are straight up
because you love me I'm looking at the
camera when I say that you love me she
loves me because yet you just you know
and I know that and it's funny because
when you told the story to Adam ray when
he was on the show and you can see how
he's like I would have reacted the same
[ __ ] you know yeah but it's a psychopath
- yeah but it's like but it's like I
know I get both like I know that you're
doing it to help me yeah measure it but
at the time though I just remember you
were like fighting me like you did yeah
cuz it's not it's not uh it's just not
black and white like though I think
they're I still I still get where that
poor kid was coming from because it's
not black and white there are valuable
things about that yeah of course to hold
on to try it going there's my there's
not but there's nuance in it that's what
I'm saying - yeah yeah obviously there's
nuance in it but it is black and white
when it comes to the goal is getting the
job yeah yes I understand there's no
nothing else mattered I know yeah
because this is a business you know what
I mean like you're not this isn't like
you go on a summer camp or you're right
it's not some Church thing no it's like
I need this to pay my rent all right you
know what I mean so like we love it and
we value the the journey right like oh
man I just did something but it is
goal-oriented yeah yeah result is result
already yeah it's like the result is to
book the job right and it's like it's
just amazing to me how bullshitty mm-hmm
everyone isn't a business I know and I
know you think I'm from a cast on - yeah
when you get on set I know and I know
you probably youth I feel like you think
I have like Stockholm Syndrome with the
TV show creator like you're like you you
still like him
no because listen because okay the only
one time mm-hmm one time I've been at an
audition where the smoke became fire yes
that's a perfect way to put yeah yes
smoke became fire and it was for blunt
talk okay you know the guy was like you
know I brought you in because I saw you
at the improv I thought you were funny
and he's just a weird dude you know what
I mean right he's like you know I was
like okay yeah see you you know and sure
enough I had this little part they
brought me in for this thing and I was
like okay cool and then on set you know
again more smoke you know I was good
we'll probably move good see we can use
you but then as I'm leaving and I'm in
my car they call me in a car and a
producers like they want you to come
back right I wrote you some lines right
now so sit so we can set up that you're
gonna come out great and that turned
into doing like you know I don't know
seven or eight episodes you know any
episode series and the thing is is I
think that sometimes the smoke is just
smoke they're just blowing smoke up your
ass yeah which is where the phrase came
from but the
sometimes I think it is it just takes a
lot longer than you than you thought
because even like with this casting
director two of the three jobs I just
booked in the past two months were with
the same casting director and she's been
blowing all kinds of smoke for years now
and a year would go by in between so I
could easily just go okay this is
[ __ ] but eventually it did know I'm
a job different well tell you why that's
different because a casting director
saying to you I think you're gonna do it
it's belief that she has in herself that
she could pick talent bragging asking
director like right and they keep
bringing you in for auditions that she's
already done it that right that's the
fire right right fire as she's saying I
was calling you in giving you a shot
exactly because they can only do someone
they can only do so much they can only
do that they can't call you in and you
make them look good by being consistent
because yeah and even if they go oh you
were great you know I look it's like I
just I know I so I'm at the point now
where I just so hate hearing that right
so I love telling my date man is like oh
so they hated me right loved you they
just went with someone else
yeah I mean they can all be true though
like like uh sometimes it's just not
your job man yeah I get it I got I get
to this like yes I understand that it
could be true and I maybe it's like okay
live in a positive world right now so
it's like you know so yes there's some
middle ground you know the new wants
there is to be like yeah you don't got
to be cynical all the time but I just
feel like when I'm saying that to
someone else I'm looking at them and I'm
being like oh that person might not be
managing their expectations prompt right
right well yeah and and that's the crazy
thing about it is that someone can take
you being like doesn't matter as being
like what do you mean my feelings don't
matter but really what you're doing is
trying to like help them through the
situation yes and make sure they don't
get more hurt later right I'm trying to
help you with your feeling right if I
can see a person is like such a I feel
everything then it's like whoa you think
the business for you yeah yeah
everything and you can tell that to you
know a million people and they're not
all gonna be ya ready to hear it you
know
I'm sure I wasn't you know yeah I know
but it is what it is I mean you came
from Baltimore you know you're at Ben's
actually a fabulous musician actually
when I first met you you were doing
music mostly well I've always been kind
of doing the same thing but at the time
I thought I could really juggle both in
a way that I've realized but you wanted
to be like a rock star type of musician
yes I'm coming to see you quite a few
years shows yeah in the beginning I've
actually played a couple shows but they
were I mean you were the only one who
came which is why I stopped doing them I
have one other friend who came to a show
and that's like so valuable
I've never the word the Viper Room yeah
that was I mean and it's cool well I
think it was and it's cool and I think
it was and it's cool that of all places
it was the Viper Room a place that's
crazy history but I yeah I mean knowing
that weird though like when you came to
LA so here's a weird thing about the
business yeah so you like you're in
Baltimore you playing music you're in a
band you're doing all your stuff with
your guys you're making great music and
all you get to LA and maybe there's a
thought in your head like one day I'll
play the Viper Room right yeah and then
it's like you played it to nobody and
then you realize oh this really this
isn't really what it means to make it
well of course not then we have these
weird ideas yeah it's the same thing for
me it's like I remember going like I
just want to do a national commercial
right you know yeah that's when you have
no idea given you what anything is yeah
dude I remember the first commercial I
ever did was fight for um it was for the
lottery California lotto
oh is it local it was local yeah yeah it
was a regional yeah it's a shop top shop
to look it up so I go I'll never forget
it was like a 10:00 a.m. call time you
don't set do nothing everybody's really
nice I'm sitting I like a trailer with
other people it's a really nice trailer
and then it was like at noon I hadn't
done anything yet right and knew all we
have lunch okay it's lunch lunch time
excitement slowly you know no but it was
like I was still kind of like alright
and then like lunch was like shark they
had shark for lunch it was it was like a
really nice very regional yeah it was
like this local it was like so good the
food was delicious okay so after lunch
it like okay get ready and then I go on
set and I shoot for like not even an
hour of what I had to do so it was like
I was in an office and it was like we
won the lottery it was like cubicle
shots and it was like excitement
so they got my shot already yeah and
that was it then I went home and I was
like oh I want to do this yeah you
notice I had a regular job at the time
oh yeah so that was like your turning
point yeah oh this is a much better job
yeah yeah because like I live in LA I
was from LA so I couldn't like and that
wasn't really doing comedy to the point
where I was a working comedian where I
can like quit my job or anything like
that so I had to have a commercial agent
so it was like but I was like oh I want
to be on set like being on set is fun
you know that's a part of what's so kind
of devastating about the downtime is
you're like man life is so much better
when you're on set you know and I was
actually talking to them about it on set
last time cuz like so almost like tying
my shoes or something and it dawned on
me I was like oh you know this is the
kind of [ __ ] that makes some actors
think that like they're kings and queens
when we're yeah
you're tying my shoe because I'm a prop
not because exam the king of the jungle
here you know not that important yeah
and it's it's so you start to realize
like how actors have misinterpreted
what's going on also sure don't touch
that oh it's because I'm like a queen no
it's cuz they don't want your fingers
roughed up for the close-up that were
about to get you know whatever it is
whatever yeah yeah you're like the car
and a car commercial they have to make
it shiny yeah they're just once you you
know it's like when you're at set and
you go this is the big one for that and
I think we've been talking about this
before but we're talking about it for
the people it's like when you're sitting
you go I'd like to get breakfast and
they go yeah we'll get it for you right
we're right what would you like it's cuz
they don't want to lose you exactly cuz
they're not what we want to take care is
if they want to get eyes on you and they
want to know we want to make sure your
dumb ass is right where you're supposed
to have because when they go we need
been on set yeah someone needs to go
I've I thought he's right here Ben we
need to unset and then I go we've got
Ben flying in a set and then that's
another moment you can go like ego bends
flying in
like there's all these moments like that
where you can you could grab on to and
really take the wrong mess let's see
that's just keeping perspective I think
you have more perspective now say than
you did when you first start yeah
you know it's just perspective it's like
you know when you're on set I you know I
always look for like the people that I
tend to find out what's going on or like
the camera people grips and yeah as you
can see what kind of set it is yeah
based on how they're you know I mean
yeah yeah yeah they're right there my
favorite to interact with and I like to
have a good attitude on said remember I
just did this Netflix movie and we were
in Boston and we were like um the
outskirts of Boston like Salem or
someplace this little town yeah so and
we took over this little area so like
everybody in the area like you know they
were just so loving it they were just
outside on their porches Oh watching and
everything like that but it was like I
could tell it was hard for the crew
because it was weird hours late hours it
was cold you know yeah so I came on set
hey hey man you know and then a guy came
out to me later he was like hi man
thanks for being that's cool you know we
needed the morale boost that's cool man
yes when I did that I just did this
lunatic role for a show on truTV called
Tacoma FD and I played a psycho who's on
drugs for it and so instead of just like
doing my scene and then like closing
back in on myself I'm like reaching out
and like you know kept trying to connect
with everyone on set and by the end of
the shoot it was you know the script
supervisor was complimenting my perform
that would not have complemented my
performance you know if I hadn't made
myself available to them throughout the
day they I don't think they would have
been you know as warm the the at the end
of the day you know what I'm saying
yeah I'm really nice so I don't know
what's right or wrong you know I don't
know I think just having as much fun as
you can and I mean I'm not in a position
to tell you but and from my experience
it's just been having as much fun as I
can try to just being as nervous you
know and but but really trying to
[ __ ] enjoy it because it could be
twelve months before I'm back you know I
know it's same with me and do and that's
that's a crazy thing right there is that
I feel that way but then you'll you'll
see an inner
you with like Meryl Streep and she feels
that way yeah where she's like every job
I think is my last job
I heard Melissa McCarthy say it that's
like a really that says common as um
what's it called when everyone goes to
everyone that's successful that ends up
going to a freaking psychotherapist
being like I'm a fraud whatever there's
a name for that at everyone's yelling at
their podcast right now I know but I I
feel that way I always feel like I feel
like that's it for me I'm out of the
business yeah you know I mean I think
it's like it's such a weird exciting
cycle you know it's like cuz this is how
it'll go like you know you're sitting
there nothing's going on email comes in
right you have an audition for such a
such role and go to make it my favorite
point you know and then all of a sudden
you're like yes yeah yeah okay the world
opened up yeah the world's open and now
you're like okay you work on your
audition yeah you do your [ __ ] and then
like you know you go in there maybe you
get a callback right and then they're
like all right you know you're pinned or
whatever and then you're like oh my god
like you're literally your life could
change again for six months or whatever
it is yeah just offer like a one email
yeah and the crazy thing about it is
like the day of work will be a Wednesday
and the audition came in the Tuesday
before so it's like a week ago this
opportunity didn't even exist yeah you
know and now I'm now I have a job or
whatever that's it that's my but I've
gone through some like really in it I
knew about like I say um managing
expectations and your emotions because I
remember I was on the road I was in
Florida I remember this car stain and a
[ __ ] condo this stupid town I was in
Tampa Florida and I got an audition for
Tom pop of the comic he had a he was a
sitcom sitcom I remember this you know
what and I'm doing like I do the thing
by myself have to set up the camera to
do all this blyat if they record the
other line yeah while recording the
other lines I got my [ __ ] technician
yeah get it in like we have a little
mini-me buddy with us he's like I'll be
doing tapes today boss yeah like I have
some key grip this is on a road with
like no I have to take paintings off my
wall and [ __ ] yeah I know this all
out this is so annoying in it so I
figured out how to do it and I got this
call back first question they ask me is
how'd you do that because they knew was
my voice oh wow really seems like oh man
how do you know so I think it was like
that was exciting to them but anyway
well what all I went through with that
it was like that audition three more
auditions right you know producers and
then it was like then that was the first
time I tested for a sitcom you know and
that was weird you know I remember I was
I remember this I'm out of town okay so
I'm a big personality so that was
supposed to be his best friend and then
all my auditions I'm being me you know
hey I'm doing what I do right and then I
remember this you know yeah and then I
get this call from Tom papa the day
before the test they had a network test
in a studio test they used my tape for
the studio test okay they pass but we
loved them and then it was like the
network test now they want me to come in
okay so I come in the day before the
test Tom papa coffee goes innocent you
know CBS you know they want you to be
grounded and like all this I do the
opposite do the it's like they're
sending me everything that we've all
loving that got you here for three weeks
yeah yeah yeah everything that got you
to this point yeah don't do that anymore
right and do it our way so I go in and I
go it was terrible yeah I'm walking out
and the guy who the producer comes
running back hey hey okay remember that
note we gave you don't do that do the
first thing again the thing you've been
doing this whole time
really yeah so it's like you know and
it's like that kind of stuff of course I
didn't I didn't get it they actually
they actually downgraded apart from
series regular to just recurring they
gave it to Malcolm Jamal Warner which is
he's like my nemesis now that's how it
happened and then they showed aneema get
big DAP yeah of course [ __ ] show
didn't even get picked up guys so it was
it was you know it's a crazy like you
had that experience for that that sitcom
you were going through so much right man
I mean well cuz yeah it's such a I feel
like I mean you just described it's such
a any human being would experience it
the same way at the roller coaster so
we're gonna over the master you're gonna
feel that no matter what and that's
actually what I actually really
respect about Bill in that situation is
that he knows that and he makes it clear
that he's doing his [ __ ] best to make
it as easy as he can on you no one gives
you a really good yeah bill Lawrence he
gives you a really nice spiel in the
first one where he goes if at the end of
this audition you feel like you didn't
give your best tell me we'll do it again
and he's like and he doesn't make you
feel like you'd be putting them out to
do that it's very nice and it makes you
as comfortable as you can they they did
the tapes where they send the tape in
instead of because I've done that where
it's a room with three tiers or worse
either seat those are the worst that was
the one if you I don't know if you
remember this where I did it and I'm
already like a high strung guy anyway
then the characters high strung and then
it's the moment and and the contracts
I've just signed oh yeah they make you
do that before you go in the room when
you go in to test for our sitcom they
make you sign your deal before they say
yes or no to whoever they're gonna pick
so you're signing a deal that says
thirty thousand an episode and you know
and it's like a five season it so you
you're when you sign that you already
spending the money the money's in your
hand yeah you know what you're gonna
lose your threes well yeah buy your
house these are the shoes I'm getting
yeah yeah I wish they wouldn't do that
[ __ ]
yeah dude if they and yeah they know
they shouldn't do that to for sure
because I did it I did the thing and
then the creator the show pulled me
aside and he was like you won't do it
again
he was straight-up was just like that
was your energy it was like you're all
your choices were clouded cuz it was
just like to your alright it was just
like too much he was like do you know do
you think it was you know he was kind of
like do you think you're ready to be in
a show kind of thing and I was like yeah
no obviously not
he's just like I think you're ready to
and I'm like yes sir and and then I did
it again and I got I broke the ice as
soon as I came in I was like I'm not
nervous anymore and that got a laugh
from everyone but I still didn't get
that no I mean but I was up against this
kid who killed me do you remember this
the kid had like and this was way back
when Amazon was still new and he already
had a whole Amazon series under his belt
his resume killed me he was shaking
hands with everyone in the office they
all already knew who he was I mean it
was just like a complete uphill battle
but it was definitely between me and him
because the other kid was like
around still looking at the lines I was
like well it's not you that's so it's
either me or mr. knows everyone and it's
probably mr. knows everyone
I feel like Andrew and I wouldn't like
that for uh since you know yeah for
Santino and I would like to add for him
dying up here cuz we had a test from
Donna pure okay the same roles no no he
was they had to test for like certain
roles knows for his role yeah I roll
yeah yeah yeah here's more ride well I
think another role so we were at
Showtime and I walk in and I see him you
know for some reason you know when you
go to a commercial audition you can kind
of feel it but you know you go to a
commercial audition everybody's cool
it's like it's a fun yeah yeah he's
probably something funny and everybody's
kind of like yeah you go to what even if
or even for a comedy right right in
theatrical right everybody's and I see
Santino go for different parts cuz you
know and so we were like so cool we're
just laughing we're telling store which
is really having a good time it's
probably how you got the role to do we
had such a good time in the Edit but
then I look around and then we're we him
and admire laughing about like how
serious that guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude one second it's not gonna get
it I booked a commercial and I swear it
was because there was there was ended up
being this vibe of camaraderie outside
the audition room in the waiting area
and so then by the time we came in our
our energy was so positive and and like
clean that I swear that's why we got
that so I bet that made you guys yeah
well you ever had looked great in the
room so you ever had I have two
experiences well I have one main
experience where I knew I was gonna book
the job yeah yeah I mean like yeah I
went in I was like I'm booking this yeah
because of what was happening right the
way they look at you when you're leaving
the room yes watch you leave the room
you pray they were laughing actually to
guys cuz like that the the Christmas
Chevy commercial I knew I was gonna book
that nice yeah I just knew it that's
such a good feeling you know yeah and
other time was when I did that but like
commercial dad I got [ __ ] on for
residuals well really what happened
remember I don't know if I knew you
didn't cut you out no no
oh that's another was that the one where
you're walking down the hall and yeah
yeah yeah it's like the joke was like a
swear jar yeah yeah they actually use
that first of all the commercial one Amy
they use it at they use it in
advertising class yeah you know it's
like it's just food ICCA's you're the
real simple premise the guy walks into
an office and he says hey what's this
secretary goes oh it's a swear jar every
time we swear we're gonna put money in
it and he said what do you do with the
money and she goes mobile probably by
you know case a Bud Light yeah then he
goes [ __ ] yeah yeah I put some money in
but then the whole thing they bleep it
yeah so that was the whole joke right so
the joke is my my one line and the thing
as I walk down the hallway and I go [ __ ]
you Bob yeah yeah yeah you're Tom yeah
so I remember the audition I'd never
forget this it was me and the other guy
we were the first ones there of the day
so the guy was setting up oh so they're
still figuring out what they want for
the spot you're the guinea pig so the
guy was like okay well let's figure out
what we're they don't you know yeah when
they're first they don't even know what
the audition is even know what he wanted
to do Jack they don't know what it is so
but the my thing was like to my tip one
of my tips always tell you yeah make a
choice make it but no to joke - mm I
give us a commercial oh yeah and
whatever the joke is once you know the
joke then can like play on the joke yeah
so I did I was like you know I just was
saying different [ __ ] you know I saw it
was like [ __ ] you that I walked and I'll
say eat my all I was just saying my dumb
dumb [ __ ] so I got you a call back and
that was with this other guy who I
didn't know so we're like doing our
thing so they set up scenarios yes the
other thing meeting someone for the very
first time and you have to have a
15-year relationship so this guy though
was trying to be extra funny and I'm a
comic and it was like getting a work bro
yeah but if you want to do it like that
you know I mean yes he's not with you
he's next you know what I mean yelling
of what he's actually doing in the room
it's like he's just like I'm gonna we're
gonna be in there together but I'm just
gonna do this and you're not I've
literally added them with the guys like
ahead of me in the room just literally
auditioning without now and we're like
scene partners he's just on to a
different beat without me I'm like
right man yeah this guy was saying [ __ ]
you know cuz I like I got again I got to
joke you know we're saying you know [ __ ]
you with cursing and that's the whole
part of the joke but you know I remember
this is the moment I knew I was gonna
book the job he says [ __ ] you Tom and I
say hey how was your [ __ ] why it's like
so cathartic by the way to be able to
say [ __ ] like that in a commercial
audition so I say that and the room
explodes cuz it's all married dudes it's
all that [ __ ] Sony so then you know I
then the guy I forgot what the guy even
said to me so I just pretended like okay
and I'm walking out yeah and then the
guy tries to get in another one and then
I say something else behind my back yeah
and I walked out of there like a book
dad yeah yeah yeah no I but and I did I
looked it you know what I mean and it
was like and even while I was on set
they were like let's do those lines that
you did it to think oh that's great so
it's like that's one of the experiences
I've had where I was like oh and thank
God you got that because I've heard that
they'll they'll like people's lines and
not book them and take their take their
lines and give them to whoever that book
they still do that so yes I think so you
have like a really good commercial
experience where you walked out of there
like that's mine yeah I would like you
like we're talking about I mean I think
it's on a spectrum and sometimes you
can't tell if it's smoke you know cuz
sometimes I've definitely had auditions
where it feels it feels like I probably
got it you know a very rare that I'm a
hundred percent but like I mentioned
there's a way I've noticed that they'll
watch you leave the room that usually
when I see that look or feel that vibe
or whatever it is I get it there's a
thing cuz like I feel like when you
don't when you're not gonna get it
they're back down at their papers
looking at what's next when you are
gonna get it they're like that's the guy
Wow I always say it's like there's
certain questions that they ask so if
they ask like if they ask me they'll go
like do we shave your mustache
hmm that's not one of them right well
I'm saying I'm saying that's one of them
Oh cuz they're like we're considering it
yeah they ask you they ask you certain
well they wrestle now they ask you that
right up top now now they're like when
they're slating you when they're like
getting your and I know they do they do
it but I also you're saying this they do
it again this was like yeah this was
like at your end they were like hey it's
that girl like you know that hey are you
available on such-and-such right right
right right now
yeah so many of the opposite experiences
too because what you think you got it
you didn't this is what I was this is
this is when you start learning to
measure and this is one of it yeah I it
was between me and someone else all
right
good they call me in and the guys like
is a director it was like Eric you're my
guy you're my choice already shut the
[ __ ] up
I want you I your my selection but they
want to see this one thing you know yeah
I didn't book that you know I mean then
I was like I was like those words are
daggers of death yeah yeah I told you
when that stupid I'm still State Farm
Chris Paul I know I we actually both
auditioned for this got a lot further
there you know date they called me like
they need a third audition you know and
I go well Cassie said look you don't
have to do it if you don't want to blah
blah blahdy but they would like to to me
I realize that was them not to choose if
they wanted me find a reason not to pick
you know find a reason not to pick me
because I think they were probably
struggling here a part of like well that
guy was on the office and yeah oh well
you know where Hawkes was on his big or
like whatever their choices were
whatever was going on on their head I
went in and solidified like let's just
go together go right if only they could
see the future you don't mean just those
came out bad I I'll say it nobody like
so oh god I was then every time I go to
that casting office
the guy who mentions it like you know
the director he wanted you he was gonna
send you some whiny stop you know that's
Scott right at that office so I'm like
I'm like that guy's a weirdo but but
what I'm saying is I guess an example
where what I'm saying to you is like
I believe this guy mm-hmm I believe the
director wanted me you wanted to send me
why I believe all that you know man
right it doesn't and right back to it it
doesn't matter when it comes down to the
bottom line and the result but it does
matter in the nuance of just like well
now you know yeah I'm definitely the
[ __ ] you know like I'm definitely good
enough just well I never doubted that
well it seemed that's fair and of course
but like for me it's easy to go like am
i delusional you know what I mean and so
even when you're not booking them
sometimes for me in my experience it's
been like I'll take it you know I'll
take the we almost had you because
that's enough to keep me here for a
couple more weeks so I totally get that
as different levels yeah but like you
know but I think you're talking about
the name thing on nobody but even but
but even everybody has levels of
delusion where at whatever level yeah
because you still think like for me I'm
like you know so yeah my thinking like
will ever be the star of a show right
right you know I always gonna be like
the third fourth fifth guy like so like
you know it's like a my delusions I
could think that right right I'm going
out to be the husband of such-and-such a
number two in a call sheet right am i
delusional you know it's like we all
have yeah but like you well yeah I mean
in delusion has a bad rap because it's
actually I feel like it's required for
all the greatest things that we
experience in life
unreasonable enough to try you know I
saw I wish I could remember what it was
there's a word for like like a word
that's synonymous with like being
practical
you know like the whole definition of it
is like basically just like not taking
chances or whatever you know that I wish
I could remember exactly what it was but
it was like it was something that dawned
on me when I was looking at the
definitions of words or some [ __ ] and I
realized like oh if the word was on
idealistic and it was like oh if you're
uh Nydia list 'ok then you're practical
and it's kind of like if you have no
ideals you never invent anything or or
do anything great you know nothing would
exist without an ideal yeah you have to
think like I have to go onstage feeling
like I'm the greatest comic to ever look
yes so it's I have to feel like that
yeah you don't have to be a little bit
technical sometimes which is a crazy
thing for me personally to deal with
because I've as I've aged a little bit I
have like gotten more and more into
practicality but it's like everything
else you kind of gotta balance it and be
like no it's okay to be a little bit
yeah I think the older you get the more
like pragmatic you be kind of our price
just one comfortable shoes yeah we're
just kind of [ __ ] with debt but that is
that takes away from like that fire and
creativity yeah yeah so it's hard to so
that's what I'm struggling with I'm
trying to be like okay well you know
keep it going but that's why I started a
podcast yeah I'm doing this and you've
always told me and it's a huge thing
that's what kept me here and we both
know I've gotten very close to leaving
is you've always said that you don't
fail in this business you quit yep
and that'll fill that's like the Erik
with Erik Griffin quote Erik Griffin
blow know where I got that from but it's
not the same wish I get cuz it's like
because I'm just tired of people asking
me like what do i do how do I make it
what do I you know start trying and
don't stop trying but it's so disgusting
when you look back now and then some new
person comes to you and goes hey you
know I wanted to commercials you just
like kids the [ __ ] out of my face yeah I
mean cuz it's like what do you want me
to tell you like you're trying to skip
so many steps right now this whole
process
yeah skipping steps is [ __ ] it's
like getting onto a like a [ __ ]
famous podcast with no TV credits I'm
not no dude it is it is though cuz like
this is the craziest thing about the
podcast universe is that I'm from
Maryland like like you mentioned and
I've never told any of my friends from
Maryland for better or for worse about
any of you guys you know for you know
for whatever reason I don't think it's
ever come up and they all know about all
of your podcasts if they're all D'Elia
fans I mean my buddy
Matt Halpern is in I think I told you
this recently he's in like magazines as
being like you know voted best drummer
in the country and the dudes we're and
crystally emerged in his like promo
videos you know and I didn't tell him
about Chris you know so it's like it's a
it is you guys are all world [ __ ]
famous man it is the world-famous Comedy
Store and people know about all you guys
yeah it's amazing thing that's coming on
but you know like I say guys you know if
you're out there and you have a dream
because people always ask me you know
like I want to do a podcast I'm gonna do
be a comic I wanna do this and that it's
just a matter you just have to just go
out and do it yeah and like you know it
wasn't do you ever do you ever like go
to like a commercial audition and just
be like oh my god this is so dumb
yeah man I've had ones where I where I
want to leave for sure and and then when
I did the audition been like I should
have left can happen to me one time I
had I had one result no no you go
I don't remember my exact Oh mine was
like it was for like a thrifty
commercial it was something like back to
school yeah and what they did was they
took a song like they took a song like a
van Halen song or no it was music since
it was Steven Tyler's band Aerosmith it
was an Aerosmith song yeah okay what's
one of their big songs it was about I
feel like I auditioned for the
tournament
and they wanted to change the words -
like rulers and pencils you know it was
the first time you're like I'm
embarrassing myself
exactly yeah it was the first time I was
like oh cuz up until that point I go to
these auditions and even if it's silly
or whatever it is I find some fun in it
and it's and it's actually usually like
helpful to like I shouldn't be taking
myself that seriously anyway this is
good for me don't take myself that
seriously to be someone who [ __ ]
stupid this one was so dumb yeah man
like sometimes I see oh you know what I
can't do the one the commercial that I
always cringe at is that you ever see
that the JG Wentworth you know what
they're doing about the people who
didn't get it I'm glad you do that and
don't get a job imagine they're at home
mad yeah that was number two that's oh
that reminds me of your life okay yeah
that reminds me of why I never dress up
for auditions now is because I went down
on like one of our hundred n to 110
degree LA days to an audition for a
valet and I get there and
all these [ __ ] are in tuxedos it's
115 degrees outside
oh [ __ ] yourself yeah I all in tuxedos
I'm wearing a t-shirt and jeans I booked
the job yeah I'm never dressing up for
you guys you know I've never stopped
thinking about how those guys had to be
miserable for a day for nothing you know
it's like man wear a t-shirt yes
sometimes I they'll be like you know we
want you when I first started I was all
about it
right right wearing scrubs yeah I bought
this on eBay had a doctor drive my lasso
let's go everybody's got a lab coat
that's for any like scientist doctor
whatever yeah they'd have like a closet
full of all these [ __ ] like [ __ ]
football jersey no I used to wear a
t-shirt that says sports on it if they
wanted a jersey remember remember also
what people would have those [ __ ]
headshots worse like you as like a
fireman as the character yeah yeah
here's me as a policeman and be like it
woody what policeman looks like that the
craziest part is they might actually
need that shot because you you would
hope I remember being so disappointed by
this when I first started acting you
think oh I'm in a creative industry now
these people have imaginations they're
all visionaries dude if they want to if
they want to see what you look like
shaven they want they need you to like
shave in the room you know what I mean
they can't they need to see everything
usually I think it's amazing how the
business part of it like infiltrates and
clouds like yeah stifles creativity oh
all of artistic expression and then a
lot of them just straight-up
aren't actually creative people you
bright you know it's the one thing too
it's like they're just not every casting
director otherwise they'd all be
award-winning casting directors there
it's actually what makes casting
director great is that they are
visionaries and creatives and so most of
them aren't going to be most of them
should be like there's really don't look
like your headshot okay
well I'm here now so you want to do this
audition or not why should we move
forward or do you not know what the [ __ ]
you're doing I've had some really good
ones I think the best can yeah kind of
wish I could member this lady's name but
like
that show time showed that they canceled
all the camps I'm dying up here that's
that one it was the one the one that was
like they were roadies oh yeah yeah yeah
Cameron was a Cameron Crowe oh yes yeah
so the casting director for that roadie
because I went out for roadies right and
you auditioned for Cameron right yes I
remember one of the best audition
experiences yes yeah man you know he he
holds the camera oh wow you know and
he's like on you like this close oh I
remember this story now and he's just
like okay I do it this way you do it
that way yeah that's like so cool oh
you're like I'm with a real creative
right right right yeah yeah but that
casting director that would be casted
that she was great too because I'll tell
you this is a tip for you actors out
there this is a real like hear me right
now this is the acting episode I know it
would be but I don't know what we're
gonna do either we talked about
everything else in our normal lives but
this is important
be prepared for your audition but be
prepared like don't just think you know
or I'm gonna do it this way it is best
to work with someone it's best to work
with someone who and try it different
ways yeah you know because this is what
I learn from this case because I did it
she was like let's do it again and so
you better not be married to that first
thing you did yeah able to let it go
let's do together and she gave me some
tips and stuff and I thought not every
cast director does this for you right
they're expecting you to settle there
all the options and all the choices I
make all the changes and make all the
big choices and so it's like be prepared
for the job yeah when you go audition
yeah like really know the lines really
prepare make a choice and then try it a
couple different ways don't be married
to one way right because it does make a
difference yeah and yeah and it's I mean
it's you but you also have to kind of
just also be able to throw because a lot
of I feel like a lot of actors who are
you know real actor actors they say like
prepare prepare prepare and then on the
day throw it all the way of course right
but though it's like cuz in and I feel
like that's because
you need to be available to shift and
change dwelling on if they have things
they want to see one thing one of the
signs of them wanting you to get the job
is adjustments when you adjust at the
audition to write write write write do
this I like that when we try this you
have to be able to do that [ __ ] another
thing I feel like actually could be a
tip for actors is I've I found like when
I booked that zombie role um I told them
what I liked about the scene in the room
so they know that I get it you know what
I mean like the thing you're saying
about get the joke
yeah I'll literally tell them like like
like the line was you know she goes like
[ __ ] I signed the waiver and it
absolves me of all responsibility in the
characters line was that's not how it
works man and he's talking to a woman so
it's just like I love that he calls her
man that's so funny and just telling
them that that couldn't like you know
puts a cable in somehow it like connects
you to the job more somehow you just
have to know what's happening in this
scene even if it's not what they want
right you know even if it's not what
they want know what you think it is yeah
let them see it yeah maybe you changed
their mind right and that's also that's
why I always say when they say when they
say up top they'll go do you have any
questions for us
usually I say I have a little it's you
know it's just the easiest thing to say
I'll say uh no I think I think I get it
uh but if it's worth your time
afterwards and I'm Way off let me know
yes I like I'm like I just so it's like
it lets them know that you understand
their time is you you believe their time
is valuable and you know that you're you
accept it if you did it wrong and they
don't think there's any hope for you
like yeah send me home
um if I if I get it way wrong let's go
thank you I get that that's fine but if
you think there's a chance I can adjust
it and make it more like what you want
it to be please you know basically like
do you see me getting this part yeah
that's essentially what yeah it's being
prepared is important because I doing
I'm dying up here there was this big
dramatic scene between me and a guy that
I went that was that the character was
in Vietnam yeah which by the way I mean
like [ __ ] so it was so
cool to see you go from workaholics
straight to that I don't like silly dude
to that yeah well just because you were
like you wanted more opportunities to do
stuff and then they were just like
here's all the [ __ ] you can do and then
it wasn't it it wasn't until then the
creator one of the creators of Kyle
right from workaholics was like oh I
didn't know he just sent me up like oh
you've really grown as a performer I
thought he was kind of like I didn't
know you could do no no he was like
you've really grown as a performer and
I'm like when I do it we were shooting
these shows at the same time yeah yeah
you're like I could have done this yeah
yeah yeah we could have done this yeah
yeah I'm like doing 57 shots of Adam and
Blake like we could have really explored
the depth of this yes like why
workaholics experience was like standing
on the other side standing in front of
the cameras with the cameras going this
way Holy Spirit working I was like okay
- shot of Blake and Blake and Anders on
ders and Blake Adam and Blake single on
Adam single on Blake single on on cut
some on Judi exactly turn around on
Montez you know Hugh Eric's life
what's up my dad's booties take it yeah
it's like one take we got it yeah maybe
a dig we we used to have to joke me and
the guy bill we had the joke on set up
you like we would bet over/under how
many takes we were gonna get no will he
turn around on us so I don't know more
than three it was like like the number
would be like two and a half I would
make jokes about who's got you and a
half so they'll just be like you know
and it was funny it was funny when I did
murder mystery we were making fun of
that too because like there's this scene
where I'm talking to Adam Sandler on the
phone but he wasn't even there I was
talking to no one I mean I'd love to see
that you because I saw in the movie I
was like actually look but like we did
that [ __ ] fast really yeah it cows like
cuz you got it man yeah yeah well I mean
sometimes that's how it is I know but I
learned on I'm dying up here the
importance of having multiple takes yeah
and be him like you know I remember had
to see when Melissa Leo and I was like I
was like in the middle of it I was like
I got do it again right right and you're
like to do this I'm gonna go
I'm gonna come back in let's do that
again you're allowed to bail on the
scene yeah you know you're gonna spend
some and she would give me some tips
she was great about that she'd be like
I'll do it this way she'd be like okay
you know if you had to say it again just
say it right then in there I know right
you know I was like oh you just learning
things yeah dude what I did that was my
first time getting a note from another
actor was when I did Grayson Frankie cuz
the scene I did my scene with was with a
Sam Robert Robertson or Roberson and
he's got an Academy Award from like the
late 80s in it forever yes so that kind
of got ya you go what do you say was it
yeah so here's like more of a pregnant
pause there's like you got it pregnant
okay
she's pregnant whatever you want man
yeah so when you work with people like
that so it's like you know it's just
it's just like so anyway I'm on I'm
dying up here and we're doing this great
V and whatever this really dramatic like
I don't even know if I could do it but
anyways they wanted me to be a part of
the audition hmm
so here can you come to audition and
then you read with the other person and
I was like sure yeah I learned so much
about her I bet additionally flash
because I'll tell you why because the
dudes that didn't know the lines
it was so distracting yeah it's not
about being obvious it was distracting
yeah
so it took away from you can't believe
the scene anymore yeah it took away from
the performance it sounds like I don't
know what you're doing if they're
looking down and it was just not even
just that just like it just the guy
didn't know and I thought he could have
been good right alright I think it's
gotta stop okay yeah so then you learned
yeah what it's like to be rooting for
someone and getting disappointed you're
like [ __ ] I don't want to do that yeah I
was like I think that guy could have
booked it if he would have known and it
came in with that what he was doing
right you know and and I also saw like
casting they have their favorites right
I also learned lying you see how they
treat them you see the guy the book did
the casting she wanted him right it was
her first choice yeah and just the way
she was like you know like what you know
jackals ready you know yes he's so sub
kind I was like doing that but me I was
like a fly on the wall yeah I was a part
of it and I was like oh this is
interesting this is why you make friends
with casting director but it's like the
thing that was like this other guy
if he would like because we would have
had ammo right that I like you're not
giving people that are rooting for you
ammo where they could be like you know
what something yes number what that guy
did we like ah he's undeniable laughter
right right but no none of them were
enough yes there's either somebody was
too dramatic there one guy came in he
was like Orion and I was like wow I was
amazing but I was like it was - you
wanna feel which you can see which
actors those are in like restaurants
you're like oh you're waiting for your
next opportunity to cry in an audition
room for sure there are a lot dude
sometimes crying is the word dude
sometimes you can hear people like going
through a therapy session and in the
audition room through a closed door and
then other times the role actually in
the case of the one I just did it called
for committing to being a nut right but
sometimes it's just like I've heard
auditions where it's like I don't think
you should be screaming the dialogue on
this one I hate hearing what they're
doing
oh yeah because I'm hollering the way
you see the scene yes you [ __ ] with
my perception man yeah usually I already
know how I like the lines to sound and
I'm just like I'll hear him and I'm like
I'm not doing it like that usually and
that's just cuz I'm Eric into [ __ ] but
yes sometimes I'll hear someone on mic
oh they're they're good you know but
sometimes you hear people and you're
like Jesus I know what are you doing
yeah what are you doing what are you
doing in there I used to I don't do that
anymore but I used to do that fairly
often where I would hear someone being
terrible and then I would kind of be try
to be the relief afterwards where I'd be
like yikes oh that last guy at a lot of
times a lot of times they would just
like drop what they were doing and just
be people with me for a while like oh my
god you have no idea what the day's been
like right you know and I'm like oh wow
this is a different kind of audition for
me now yeah they free but they forget
that they're you know yeah yeah do my
god yeah I was a one time I I tested for
dr. ken Oh his show his show and it was
cool because I had a good time because
he would read with you in early
auditions yeah but I never forget this
because I got into a I got into like a
verbal argument with the cast another
actor oh wow that was testing for the
part we were just in the lobby yeah at
like
NBC yeah he was the guy that got he's
gay
yeah I wish I could remember his name he
got the role you know he got a role he
got the role
but like we were talking it was so
stupid but we were talking about - gay
pride parade you know yeah and I was
saying like I said you almost said yeah
I hate to parade yeah and I was like you
know it's just it [ __ ] up traffic yeah
that was my point just a pragmatic
reason for not liking it that is the
only reason I like it yeah because I
have to drive from Culver City to the
Comedy Store right and that's in the
middle of the [ __ ] gay parade it
always makes it where I have to go like
I hate it
that's what I always think of right oh
and he was one of those like yeah man
yeah yes the traffic why would I just
tell everyone I hate gay people in this
in this audition room you obviously get
I think I'm trying to code it or you
think I'll try to get in your head yeah
you know what I don't want to talk about
this before the test you know I think I
helped him yeah he's doing it you let me
win in there when you used that he
didn't he definitely thought use it yeah
that that what is it but good for him
for booking the job nurse and and thank
you to you I know I see I should reach
out to him I have a friend who knows him
there's probably an interview somewhere
he worries like I hate to admit this but
Erik Griffin really feels me yeah I want
to have him on the podcast we were like
you know you were being a liberal [ __ ]
you battle remember when you
oversensitive [ __ ] and like you know
making it make it out my what you think
my opinion was and that was probably
around that time to when I was just
getting that was just getting popular oh
I know it was like yeah you wanna you
want to spice up your night leg they
should just be an outrage club this
should just be a place oh there will
automatically be one yeah sure you just
go it's like I want to be outraged it's
a silent disco or they're just
and headphones oh no you go and like or
like it's like you ever been to dicks
didn't want to Baltimore sportings good
place this morning no no it's a it's a
restaurant
Oh dicks the road where they put that
and the things in your head they beat
you like [ __ ] they treat you like [ __ ]
and that's what I do there should be a
restaurant where you go and like the
waiter says something to trigger you so
you could go off right right right right
now like a gay couple comes in and
waiter goes these people and then just
walks away to call the manager and then
there's a whole scolding of the way they
get fired in front of you yeah but then
they just come right back it's all its
own performance before they're already
great they're struggling actors it's the
new singing restaurant job yeah created
a new market I'll be talking about this
on stage so driving lift and then this
place those are the two main Dave Dave
rate moneymakers do you even imagine
being like you want to be a singer your
dream is to be a singer yes I can't
imagine yeah right and you have to work
at a restaurant where after you bring
pancakes to somebody you just step on
the oh my god but anyways people love
that darling she's great I think they
take pride in thinking they're a manager
they're like they're like I know talent
and they're like spotting you know what
you know what that is is that's them
acknowledging that someone with talent
yeah shouldn't be that just [ __ ]
rushed right right you know yeah but the
one time I felt like that is I was we go
to Nashville been in Nashville I haven't
but I've heard that everyone's
unbelievable when you go to Nashville do
you get off your plane there's like a
bar in the [ __ ] Airport and there's
like a Koran and they'll be do a dude
that like you like dis muhfucka should
have a album yeah yeah you know are you
not writing for Justin Timberlake just
Airport but that's like a legit job for
people in that yeah so many people go to
Nashville to make it that like you know
like there was one guy he was on a show
like my
haddem making the band but like in
country it's the best musicians in the
country oh sure yeah yeah but it's one
of those things though where you go
there's something psychological about
like seeing somebody would talent be at
a place that you don't think somebody
with talent should be at that's what
that whole thing was with the [ __ ]
actor from The Cosby Show being at
Trader Joe's where everyone was just
like this isn't what it is and then it
becomes and it becomes this like nerrit
and their narrative about actually what
you actually believe is a lesser job and
what you think you'll sense value and
doesn't the people that were trolling
him or making him feel bad about that
right I'm not with that well but wait
wait I don't know if anyone did no no
they were well that was the dude that
was the whole thing
oh that's why nobody was up in arms
could everybody were like you know you
were looser you know they were I don't
know if anyone I thought the whole thing
was that like it was almost the converse
of that where they were accidentally
inadvertently making him seem like a
loser by being like there's nothing
wrong with this and it was like no one
says anything with the liberal folks
then all right those are people that
should be at my restaurant yeah yeah
then you're then you are saying there's
something wrong with it no there were
people that were like they were good
like for me if I'm looking at it like
matically if I'm looking at it like you
know critical thinking about it my own
perspective this is just my own
perspective when you see that you're
gonna be like it's like you might think
to yourself Oh what happened
right like like why didn't you continue
or like what like you didn't save your
money or start thinking all these
they're a victim of something yeah cuz
you go you don't got no Cosby money yeah
yeah there's no like residuals all right
yourself you must have find a bad deal
yeah like that's what I think of when I
saw that I go dear because it would be
like if I start driving lift right if
I'm gonna lift you walk if you get into
a lift and you go oh she Montez right
right
they understood your arch yeah whatever
yeah that's what I would say four years
researching apart yeah yeah if we get to
keep saying if you know or you just be
like been my lyft driver 44 times no
it's your search or you just go or
you're somebody the other side of that
is like it could be somebody that I like
and I hate chip is nacelle business
my money's in the bag I didn't make a
ton of money I just made enough to
survive and I like you know being around
people you know yeah there's people like
that but it's just weird like the
mentality of once you've put somebody on
a fake pedestal that's what it is
well that's what it is you don't want to
see we want to knock them off we don't
want to see them off right but I want to
be a part of knocking you off cuz in a
way it's it's the it's a projection
thing I think where you go like oh what
are my dreams then if your dream you
know didn't do anything you know like
your success did now do what I thought
it would do for you therefore wouldn't
do what I thought it would do for me
yeah what am i what am i working towards
that I feel like that might be one part
of it there's just a matter of like you
know but it's funny though like when
you're on the come-up you're still there
you're gonna come up yeah you're trying
to like you know so it's like that's
always fun yeah that's all yeah there's
always like you'reyou're it's like
something ahead there yeah Rises you're
always rock climbing you test you're
always you know you're doing this all
the time all the time but once you
actually achieve something that's like
life-changing yeah after that there's no
climbing right sometimes you're climbing
and sometimes like whatever your real
holes were that you thought it would
fill are still gonna be there there
there yes so so you know keep
perspective that's why it's been a
that's why in a big way you know working
at it for 11 years now has been a
blessing cuz I haven't been able to ruin
anything yet you know I know you know
well I guess that's a good stopping
point right now you know I had them on I
talk about them all the time
come on that's that that's get out of
the way thank you so much for having me
nobody I've been on again because I'm
actually been and I often times been is
my movie buddy
um and then now that I got an electric
car he's also my movie buddy even more
frequently because I like charging my
car I need to find chargers chargers
he's always at movies and we can like be
in the movie for two hours on my car's
charge when I get out yeah but like
let's in this clothes was like the last
movie we saw together parasite yeah we
that was which I actually paid for for
the first time in our 10-year friendship
paid for the movies this is great but
you
was weird is like your hey Gong Korean
movies because you want a Korean movies
all the time you tell me we move I used
to live in Koreatown and that's not
actually where it started
it started when I was still living in
Hollywood at the hostel I knew like I
met a movie buff who was one of those
guys that just has all the all the
horror movies no one's ever seen before
one of those types of guys and he had a
bunch of Korean movies and I saw a movie
that I didn't I knew I wanted to mention
when you brought a parasite called I saw
the devil have you ever seen that we
need to watch that together because
that's the movie that made me go what
the [ __ ] is going on with these Korean
movies right and then cut to [ __ ] I keep
bumping into the mic cut you like okay
cut to like um you know a couple years
later I'm in I'm living in Koreatown now
and there was a Korean movie theater
there and I would just go blind I
wouldn't even know what was showing I
would just walk into that place and it
was so nice by the way if you live in
Koreatown CGV theaters it's like wood
floors it's really nice in there and I
would just go in in any movie I saw
blind you know with the subtitles would
be like the best movie I've seen yeah
they make some credible movies there's
always some weird twist cuz they're so
good they're so good at setting up a
normal day-to-day life that you can that
you that you can believe and then once
you're once you're believing oh this is
the day to day these are these people
they're normal they're funny in this way
or whatever then you believe and buy
everything that they [ __ ] put you
through after that yeah a parasite yes
sort of normal any other terrible people
Clara right they're con artists yeah the
con are spoiler alert and then all of a
sudden I'm not even gonna tell you what
you should go see it but it was like it
just was such a weird that twist you
know it's the tone of it do was so
unlike anything you've ever seen yes not
even a horror movie that's the thing is
we went into it thinking it was so your
water one whole time waiting for it to
get dark and it like literally light
wise and never even gets don't never get
super dark yeah but it got it got weird
it gets real I guess we're weird and it
gets real surreal that's part of what
makes it strange it's just the
juxtapositions of the tone and the
feeling feeling really what I'm seeing
yeah y-you see you're off guard I think
you don't want any if you're gonna go
see parasite you don't want to know
anymore you should actually leave skip
ahead right now to the end
another reason to turn off this bug I
know I know who the [ __ ] he is and he's
ruining movies where woke if they were
saying that they didn't get this far
anyway thank you so much for being here
you're still here thanks for being here
with your average watch time I'm in 15
minutes on my hour and a half we just
you know it varies yeah you say who
knows because people come back to it you
know maybe they'd like to come back and
I finish you know but like yeah Paris
eyes about just family they're con
artists they con their way into this
family there you but it's like it's
funny the dialogues funny the
relationships are great yeah they're
tiny because they're so good at timing
too that's the other thing with Korean
movies they understand like physical oh
yes so they yeah so they had like this
family there's this fan trick family and
then this con artist family convinces
this family child fire the maid and the
driver so they could take over those
jobs and then the maid comes back and
she knocks on the door when your
family's gone [ __ ] creepy yeah and
she's like I just need some I thought
she was gonna kill them yeah I don't
know what's happening you're like what
is happened she goes downstairs and
she's in like a panic yeah that your
anxiety level goes up so I don't know I
won't even spoil it
cuz when you get you're watching this
you've probably watched the movie and
then maybe you want to hear about it
right who knows I guess well if you
haven't seen the movie don't I don't
know whenever I watch it I just say damn
it yeah so like she comes in this former
maid and then she goes down to the
basement and there's some kind of trap
door and and the sequence of her going
that was just it feels like they
visualized almost what it feels like to
spiral into an anxiety attack oh I know
because if you're literally going down
where there's like there's some sort of
like there's it's like like then there's
this underground cavern turns out of
this house and note that they're people
that live there didn't even know about
unsettling it's very Anza and her
husband is living down there yeah and he
was trapped in there's wrong with him
yeah he's yeah he's got PTSD from
something and so she's been and she'd
been taking care of him so then it just
spirals into weirdness from there
communicating with they don't know they
don't know you don't know yes but the
ladies communicating via a light switch
in Morse code and he slams his head at a
pattern to communicate with this kid and
so they don't know that he's been
terrifying their little boy this whole
time oh and also the little kid knows
Morse code
well not just that remember the little
kid saw him yeah or that was the
creepiest scariest part a show there
because he came up from the stairs and
he was like you know wide-eyed and it
has eyes in a kid imaginary wide-eyed
you I'm so sorry but it is it is it was
shockingly opened open cut their
statement that's why the kid was scared
so much I god this the wisdom it took a
turn just like the movie we really took
a turn to good turn and it just the
movie gets progressively weird from
there but I do recommend seeing and I
thought it was very entertaining the
reading wasn't distracting you guy get
into so I can get I can slip into and
you never want to watch subtitles but
you slip into it so fast yeah our first
big movie was a subtitle movie it was
the race oh yeah that was the first
movie that made us go like one of those
fantastic action movies ever made is the
raid and raid redemption and the raid is
another movie I saw with that same guy
who introduced me I saw the devil so
you've got to see I saw the devil you're
gonna be yeah it's one of those movies
where you're gonna be looking at me was
a movie like have you ever seen an old
boy yeah that's and that's like the feel
like that's the first one that broke
into kind of the American pop culture
well that movie is so bizarre yeah man
you know just a whole set up for him to
like you know yeah you're [ __ ] your
daughter yeah just like I mean I was
like what
sickening revenge and that's why I say
about parasite like like I keep harking
or harping harping on the the fact that
it's Korean because it's like if it is
just like so
so typically Korean in a way because
it's they're all good you know like what
like because I was you know
we're hearing all these things about
parasite is exceptional da da da and it
really is really but I think what is so
exceptional about it is it's just like
the first movie since old boy to kind of
break into America's pop culture thing
because they straight up all of them and
we're basically that good and what was
strange about it as I thought like I
could get it being a John Woo film like
if it was like a true scary movie yeah
like the ring or something like that but
this was just a straight-up its
psychological thriller yeah whatever
whatever really all over the place it
really is but anyway that's from Ben and
I I mean this is why I'll probably have
been on and there's a beer could been at
the movies have them back on again since
we watched not working with the Lee
brothers so high these are never coming
back
Steve's coming back but actually the
next time I have Steve on I'm gonna make
him take the love language test so look
out for that nice so why would I have
them with him but anyway this is Ben Ben
C word um young up-and-coming actor or a
musician but more importantly my friend
my chosen family
this guy Saul you'll see him again